[Music]
to the center of the center
the iphone 13 pro and 13 pro max are
better than you think
so really there's only three things
about this phone that are genuinely
better than the regular 13. and one of
them you could argue maybe not that many
people are actually going to notice but
the other two are pretty big jumps
and so this feels like a pretty big
upgrade
disguised in the same design as last
year so i've reviewed the iphone 13
already it was earlier this week there i
go over cinematic mode and the new a15
bionic and a smaller notch etc this pro
phone has all of that but then on top of
that the three major things that this
phone does better than the regular 13
would be the screen
the battery
and the cameras and everything in wait
marquez that's the same list of three
things you said was better about the 13
than the 12 you'd be right
but this takes a bigger leap in all
those things so to start with the screen
the 13 pro is the same size as the 13
and the 13 pro max is bigger again same
sizes and resolutions as last year but
now there's a smaller notch
neat okay looks a little better on the
bigger screen even though there is no
more information on that extra screen
but then the display is actually
noticeably brighter here even versus the
13. it hits a thousand nits max
brightness versus the 800 on the 13 and
even 1200 in its peak with hdr and it's
really good it's viewable everywhere
outdoors great responsive auto
brightness and it's still one of the
most color accurate oled panels out
there but what we're really here for
finally is apple's pro phones now
getting pro motion meaning an adaptive
high refresh rate display
it's about damn time now this has been
really interesting to watch unfold
because
it's not just a matter of dropping 120
hertz display into the phone and then
calling it a day there's a couple
different considerations and nuances and
things to be able to do to do it well
and then there's whether or not people
even notice that's two different things
so as a self-proclaimed pixel enthusiast
as someone who's seen a lot of phones
apple has done this really well and it's
of course an oled but it's also an ltpo
display meaning it's an adaptive
variable refresh rate that can ramp up
to 120 hertz but also now down to as low
as 10 hertz it actually has 12 different
refresh rates that it cycles between
which is seven more than the ipad pro so
this helps it respond to exactly what's
happening on the display so if you're
watching a 24 fps movie the display only
needs to refresh 24 times per second but
if you're scrolling through a website or
social media it'll be nice and smooth
maybe if you're gaming it's pinned at
120 hertz but if you're just sitting on
a home screen or reading some text like
an email nothing's happening on the
screen it can go all the way down to 10
hertz which can save battery so this
tech has been around for years and other
phones and it's great so the interesting
part is different phones ramp up at
different times and for different
reasons and different amounts
so an example is like no matter how high
refresh rate of an android phone i have
it's always 60 hertz for google maps
anytime i open google maps the whole
rest of the phone notification panel
using the app it's all 60 hertz probably
to save battery because it's a gps heavy
app but that's one thing it always does
so it turns out there have been a lot of
places where people have noticed the
iphone doesn't ramp all the way up to
120 hertz in fact a lot of places in
third party apps where it still stays
at 60. now i've noticed just from using
a whole ton of different apps i was
actually pretty impressed by how many
are already using 120hz animations and
all these apps inside and out felt
smoother and more responsive also all of
ios is smoother and more responsive but
for those that don't apple has put out
detailed instructions on how to make it
easy for developers to update their apps
to fully support promotion exactly the
way they want to so when your favorite
apps get updated hopefully the
developers include it but all that being
said
will regular people who get this phone
even notice
promotion
this is something i've thought a lot
about especially since the announcement
you know of course lots of other phones
have gotten higher fresh rate in the
past but because it's an iphone
this is for millions of people who have
only ever seen a 60hz phone their entire
lives this will be the first time they
ever see a high refresh trade screen
on a phone and so this is this is the
thing i've been talking about for so
long so when i actually first got this
phone i started handing it to people
you know discreetly of course but
handing it to them like hey do you
notice anything different about this
phone like swipe around maybe hold it
next to your current phone do you feel
like it feels any different and i'll be
the first to admit
not as many people immediately noticed
it as i was hoping like you know
different people had different things
about it that they noticed like there's
a really good video by joshua chang
where he did that same thing he handed
the phone to a bunch of people and they
all had different ways of explaining
what they noticed so some of them didn't
notice but some of them noticed things
like text staying more crisp on the
screen while you're scrolling
some people just straight up noticed the
better smoothness and touch
responsiveness and called that out so
i'll put it this way
not everyone will notice promotion right
away especially if they're not looking
for it
but
i don't have i'm not crazy it's not like
i have special eyes or anything so i
guarantee you this if you get somebody
used to 120 hertz
or just high refresh rate in general and
they use this phone for a couple weeks a
couple months and then you hand them
back a 60 hertz phone they will notice
that difference and they won't want to
switch back to it basically i think
people who buy this pro iphone and get
used to promotion won't want to switch
back to a 60hz iphone just like people
who switch to a higher fresh rate
android phone don't want to switch back
either but also i'm kind of hoping apple
doesn't ship another 60hz iphone next
year they definitely could but i'm
hoping like
90 hertz at least something like that
either way that's my stance on the
higher fresh rate the promotion in the
pro iphones clearly the implementation
technically speaking is pretty great
it's super color accurate it's very
bright it looks great and it's very
smooth so despite the notch and some
apps needing to be updated it's one of
the best looking screens on any phone
right now and going with ltpo let these
phones with their new higher fresh rates
also be battery champs so this is the
second big thing about these new phones
which is
holy smokes man the batteries got really
good
now there's a couple different
compounding factors that all pile on top
of each other to make this happen the
fact that the pro motion dips below 60
hertz to save you battery when you don't
need it is number one but number two the
a15 bionic is more efficient than last
year and then the fact that these phones
are actually slightly thicker and
heavier to support an actually larger
battery is a really big number three so
the battery inside the 13 pro is about
11 larger than the 12 pro and the 13 pro
max cell is about 18
larger than the 12 pro max that's not a
small amount and you can't actually feel
it in the weight these new phones are
about 20 grams heavier than last year
and probably heavier than the phone
you're holding right now and the results
have been dope i've mostly been dailying
the 13 pro here and getting six seven
hours of screen on time no problem never
really killing the phone in a day i'd
consider that an a and david's been
testing the 13 pro max here at the
studio and getting crazy endurance
numbers he had a day with five hours of
screen on time with 50 battery left
which is nuts so i'm gonna go ahead and
put the iphone 13 pro max right up at
the top of the battery champ 2021 power
rankings right now alongside a bunch of
other phones with like the super massive
batteries like the rog phone 5 and the
moto g power so screens check
batteries
check but once again the biggest change
with these new pro phones
is the cameras again so first of all i
really like that the 13 pro and 13 pro
max have the exact same set of cameras
between them so the phones are basically
identical except for screen size and
battery size so that's nice
uh but yeah once again big leap up with
the pro phones and their cameras and
they've got the camera bump to go with
it and it really is a massive like three
layer camera bump with this phone if you
don't have a case on the phone you'll
immediately notice it sits up higher it
rocks more from certain corners on a
table and it just kind of looks at you
funny remember when we thought the
iphone 12 pro had huge cameras
yeah no this is next level these are
much larger sensors and cameras in here
so we've got triple cameras still got
lidar and a mic and a flash and each of
these cameras is better than last year
in its own way so the primary 12
megapixel camera with that even larger
sensor shift stabilization
is excellent it's remarkably consistent
through various lighting and indoor and
outdoor scenarios there's also of course
the photographic styles to choose from
that i talked about in the previous
video i landed on rich contrast as my
favorite and honestly just left it there
for most of my photos
main thing you'll notice that makes it
better is the big sensor look that we
had only in the pro max last year so
this natural bokeh is so easy now that
you might find yourself having to tap to
focus just a little bit more just to
make sure you're focused on the right
thing and you'll find that you can get
that natural background blur much easier
it's not always perfect there's it's
still tiny smartphone optics but the
natural blur is better than fake
portrait mode blur every time so it does
a great job not fringing also like some
other big smartphone sensors do the
telephoto is also better this year so
it's once again a bigger sensor and it's
also now a 3x optical zoom instead of a
2x or 2.5 x from last year
and it looks almost as good as the main
sensor so you love to see that that
consistency between different cameras
gives you the confidence to be able to
switch between cameras like it doesn't
even matter which one you're using and
that's more true this year than ever
before now it's no s21 ultra you know
you're not going to do that deep double
digit zooming very well some of the best
periscope zooms literally look crisp at
10x while the iphone is maxing out at 15
and it looks like a watercolor painting
there so it's going to be up to you to
decide if that's something you care
about having in your phone or not and
then last but not least the ultra wide
again closing in on the corner to corner
sharpness of the main camera it's not
quite there but this is this is one area
where i was maybe hoping to see a higher
resolution
because you're spreading this pixel
count over such a wide focal range maybe
16 24 megapixels even would have been
cool to see just to get that true
matching sharpness nevertheless the
photos and videos from the ultrawide are
world class literally tops among any
ultrawides in any smartphone and it's
now also capable of macro photography
unlike the ultra wide in the 13 and 13
mini and honestly it's pretty good so
you can get pretty close right up to
about two centimeters minimum focus
distance and there's a pretty good
amount of you know chromatic aberration
and fringing and artifacting around the
outside of the frames but as long as you
tap to focus you can get a pretty good
close-up right in the middle and it's
way better than any crappy 2-megapixel
macro camera has ever dreamed of being
now i mentioned during the impressions
video the pro phones are doing this auto
switching where if something comes
within about 14 centimeters of the
camera it automatically switches to the
ultra wide in macro mode
doesn't tell you and doesn't let you
manually switch back honestly it's the
most annoying part of using this camera
to me i take plenty of close-ups of
objects because i have no friends i
guess and every time i switch to the
ultrawides macro it produces an
objectively worse looking photo so
apple's reached out and they have said
sense that they do plan on adding a
toggle to let you manual out of that
macro mode
i hope it gets added soon it should be a
software update can't wait for it
because my photos are suffering you know
there's still no astrophotography mode
in the iphone even though in night mode
you can sometimes see some stars if you
hold the phone still for long enough
and there's no pro mode for manual
control over photos or for videos that's
still going to require a third party app
to really dig into that stuff what they
did add is cinematic video mode which i
talked about in the 13 review to
summarize it's a 1080p 30fps hdr video
portrait mode and i really don't think
it's the answer when it comes to taking
the reins and making the best videos
possible on your iphone at least not yet
i mean if you want to tailor a whole
entire shoot around focus racking then
yes the iphones will punch above their
weight class but i found myself using
the regular video mode or even
third-party apps to get the best video
out of the iphone still but you know it
would actually help to get better video
out of the iphone prores video
giant asterisk that's not in the phones
yet so the pro iphones should also
ideally in a software update be getting
prores video for those unfamiliar that's
a high quality video codec that's used
all over the professional industry it's
a pretty sweet should be awesome to be
able to shoot prores video from your
phone
mix it with other cameras bring it into
your editor and just start chopping that
couple other small asterisks though one
prores video would be 4k 30 on every pro
iphone
except the 128 gig base storage versions
those will max out at 1080p 30fps
it's unclear if this is because you'd
just fill up the storage too fast and
they didn't want to let you
you know there could be some merit to
that 4k is big files it's like six gigs
per minute you could theoretically fill
up the whole phone in two hours if you
just shot all day
but also it could be because the slower
storage that's typically used in lower
pricing lower tiered models of less
storage might not have supported it in
the first place it's a high data rate
one or the other maybe both i don't know
but just know as long as if you're
planning on getting a pro iphone just to
shoot 4k prores video you'll have to get
at least a 256gb version and you can
actually go all the way up to one
terabyte of total storage but the tough
part about having a one terabyte iphone
13 pro full of huge prores files is
offloading that to your computer via
lightning at those awful speeds is going
to take forever it's not exactly a pro
workflow it's so brutal that for all the
big game apple always talks about usbc
and the ipad and every other thing they
do and thunderbolt
it's just never made it to the iphone
matter of fact let me use this as a
segue for all the things that i wish
this iphone pro had for a thousand
dollars number one usb type c probably
never gonna happen but i can still dream
and then faster charging and i don't
mean the 27 watts that the pro max can
apparently support from a higher powered
brick that's not included in the box i
mean like real 50
65 watt maybe even higher wattage
charging someday that again
is probably never gonna happen and i've
made a whole video about why apple
hasn't done that and some other things
like high resolution cameras etc i'll
leave a link below the like button but
nevertheless pro max's huge battery
still takes a very long time to charge
and i wish there was an all black option
ah minor detail there's always a case or
skin for that but there's a couple other
minor things that didn't quite fit into
this full review so you can turn down
the refresh rate of the display to 60
hertz limited but it's not in the
display settings like in every other
phone it's in accessibility settings
under motion
and then limit frame rate i haven't
tested this for more than about a few
minutes but i have a feeling it won't
actually save that much battery on this
phone considering it's actively bringing
you down below 60 hertz all the time
anyway
then if if you're using a magsafe duo
charger which i actually do when i'm
traveling the new camera bump on the 13
pro is so big that it actually gets
pretty close to the wireless charging
coil to the point where if you have a
case on your phone it actually pops the
phone up slightly off the charger now it
still works
but i'd be careful what case you buy
just in case you get one with a camera
bump that's too big and now suddenly it
doesn't make contact with the charger
anymore and then the new sierra blue
color just so you know is a little paler
in person than it looks in the press
materials and on apple's site just
warning you you know it's a slightly
bluish silver not that that's a bad
thing just a warning i'll try to show it
as best i can with all the footage from
the shiny new raptor camera so the minor
upgrade turns out to be pretty solid
after all
spoiler alert every iphone upgrade from
here till the end of time is it's gonna
be a minor upgrade that's the way
smartphones are but look
there's nothing wrong with a small
upgrade in my opinion that's how you
eventually get great at something is by
getting a little bit better every time
you do it
i would know that's how i've gotten
better at making videos and that's
exactly what i went over in my
skillshare course so skillshare is an
online learning community for creatives
where you can find thousands of classes
for creative and curious people on all
kinds of topics illustration photography
and now making mkbhd videos like i've
said before i'm self-taught at pretty
much everything we do here and that's
like the number one comment i get
anytime we try something a little new or
different like car videos or something
there's always comments like oh you're
not good at that just stick to regular
tech videos but how do you think people
who are good at car videos started they
had to get started somewhere and just
get a little bit better over time so
i've taken some skillshare courses
myself and there's even one on animating
four youtube videos uh by evan from the
polymatter channel that i'm super into
and he is also self-taught so hey if you
start seeing you know slightly better
animations here and there on the channel
maybe some of that is michael who's of
course doing world-class animations here
but maybe some of that is me chipping in
which would be nice but yeah for my
skillshare class it's my fundamentals
for how we put together these mkbhd
videos that's what it's all about so
skillshare is also curated specifically
for learning so there's no ads so you
can stay focused and it's less than 10
bucks a month for an annual membership
so here's the deal skillshare was kind
enough to sponsor this video and give
the first thousand of you that click the
link below in the description a free
trial to a premium membership
and what can be better than that so you
can get started with your learning and
your creativity but that's pretty much
it for the 13 pro let me know what you
think of this phone in the comments
section below we can talk about it
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]